Here’s an old quiz
problem we can use to test
our understanding of all
the factors that went
into the final design of
our ReadKey() SVC code.
We’re considering three
different versions (R1, R2,
and R3) of the
ReadKey() SVC code,
all variants of the various
attempts from the previous
section.
And there are three types of
systems (Models A, B, and C).
We’ve been asked to
match the three handlers
to the appropriate system.
Looking at R1, we see it’s
similar to Attempt #2 from
the previous section, except
it always reads from the same
keyboard regardless of the
process making the SVC request.
That wouldn’t make much sense
in a timesharing system since
a single stream of input
characters would be shared
across all the processes.
So this handler must be intended
for the Model C system, which
has only a single process.
Looking at R2, we see it’s
similar to Attempt #1 from
the previous section, which had
the fatal flaw of a potentially
infinite loop if attempting
to read from an empty buffer.
So this code would only run
successfully on the Model B
system, which *does* allow
device interrupts even when
the CPU is running
inside an SVC call.
So the keyboard interrupt would
interrupt the while loop in R2
and the next
iteration of the loop
would discover that buffer
was no longer empty.
By the process of
elimination that
leaves the R3 handler to be
paired with the Model A system.
R3 is Attempt #3 from
the previous section
and is designed for our standard
system in which the kernel is
uninterruptible.
The problem goes on to say
that a fumble-fingered summer
intern has jumbled up the
disks containing the handlers
and sent an unknown
handler version
to each user running one
of the three model systems.
To atone for the mistake,
he’s been assigned the task
of reading various user messages
sent after the user has tried
the new handler disk on
their particular system.
Based on the message, he’s been
asked to identify which handler
disk and system
the user is using.
The first message says “I
get compile-time errors;
Scheduler and ProcTbl
are undefined!”
On the right of the slide we’ve
included a table enumerating
all the combinations of
handlers and systems,
where we’ve X-ed the matches
from the previous slide
since they correspond to
when the new handler would be
the same as the old handler and
the user wouldn’t be sending
a message!
The phrase “Scheduler and
ProcTbl are undefined” wouldn’t
apply to a timesharing system,
which includes both symbols.
So we can eliminate the first
two columns from consideration.
And we can also
eliminate the second row,
since handler R2 doesn’t
include a call to Scheduler.
So this message came
from a user trying
to run handler R3
on a Model C system.
Since Model C doesn’t
support timesharing,
it would have neither Scheduler
nor ProcTbl as part the OS
code.
Okay, here’s the
next message: “Hey,
now the system always reads
everybody’s input from keyboard
0.
Besides that, it seems to waste
a lot more CPU cycles than it
used to.”
R1 is the only handler that
always reads from keyboard 0,
so we can eliminate
rows 2 and 3.
So how can we tell if R1
is being run on a Model
A or a Model B system?
The R1 handler wastes
a lot of cycles
looping while waiting
for a character to arrive
and the implication is that
was a big change for the user
since they’re complaining that
running R1 is wasting time
compared to their
previous handler.
If the user had been running
R2 on a model B system,
they’re already used to the
performance hit of looping
and so wouldn’t have noticed
a performance difference
switching to R1, so we
can eliminate Model B from
consideration.
So this message came from
a user running handler R1
on a model A system.
The final message reads “Neat,
the new system seems to work
fine.
It even wastes less CPU
time than it used to!”
Since the system works as
expected with the new handler,
we can eliminate a
lot of possibilities.
Handler R1 wouldn’t work fine
on a timesharing system since
the user could tell that the
processes were now all reading
from the same keyboard
buffer, so we can eliminate R1
on Models A and B.
And handlers R2 and R3 wouldn’t
work on a Model C system since
that doesn’t include process
tables or scheduling,
eliminating the
right-most column.
Finally handler R2 wouldn’t work
on a Model A system with its
uninterruptible kernel since any
attempt to read from an empty
buffer would cause
an infinite loop.
So, the message must have
been sent by a Model B
user now running R3.
Well, that was fun!
Just like solving the logic
puzzles you find in games
magazines :)ich
consumes 800us/10ms = 8% of the CPU.
A similar calculation shows that servicing
the disk takes 25% of the CPU and servicing
the printer takes 40% of the CPU.
Collectively servicing all the devices takes
73% of the CPU cycles, leaving 27% for running
user-mode programs.
Obviously we'd be in trouble if takes more
than 100% of the available cycles to service
the devices.
Another way to get in trouble is to not have
enough CPU cycles to meet each of the deadlines.
We need 500/800 = 67.5% of the cycles to service
the disk in the time between the disk request
and disk deadline.
If we assume we want to finish serving one
printer request before receiving the next,
the effective printer deadline is 1000 us.
In 1000 us we need to be able to service one
higher-priority disk request (500 us) and,
obviously, the printer request (400 us).
So we'll need to use 900 us of the CPU in
that 1000 us interval.
Whew, just barely made it!
Suppose we tried setting the keyboard deadline
to 2000 us.
In that time interval we'd also need to service
1 disk request and 2 printer requests.
So the total service time needed is 500 +
2*400 + 800 = 2100 us.
Oops, that exceeds the 2000 us window we were
given, so we can't meet the 2000 us deadline
with the available CPU resources.
But if the keyboard deadline is 3000 us, let's
see what happens.
In a 3000 us interval we need to service 2
disk requests, 3 printer requests, and, of
course, 1 keyboard request, for a total service
time of 2*500 + 3*400 + 800 = 3000 us.
Whew!
Just made it!se
the interrupt handler to add a character to
the keyboard buffer and call wakeup() to signal
any process waiting on that buffer.
Watch what happens when the kbdnum in the
interrupt handler matches the kbdnum in the
ReadKey() handler.
wakeup() loops through all processes, looking
for ones that are waiting for this particular
I/O event.
When it finds one, it sets the status for
the process to zero, marking it as ACTIVE.
The zero status will cause the process to
run again next time the Scheduler() reaches
it in its round-robin search for things to
do.
The effect is that once a process goes to
sleep() WAITING for an event, it's not considered
for execution again until the event occurs
and wakeup() marks the process as ACTIVE.
Pretty neat!
Another elegant fix to ensure that no CPU
cycles are wasted on useless activity.
I can remember how impressed I was when I
first saw this many years ago in a (very)
early version of the UNIX code :)